you said somewhere that you love films
that are centered around the human
condition and I know you have a
fascination with stories about jails or
citizen where does a nice boy from Alton
Illinois want to know more about that
what how does that fit into your stories
it fits into my stories because I often
think about what my life would have been
like had I not been fortunate to develop
this passion for for filmmaking I think
artists and people that do this are just
a little bit they push themselves to the
extreme there's and for me I know that
if I didn't have this to really pursue
and I was a lost soul like a lot of
other people you know with that I could
have very easily done I'm not you know
been in a position to where my energy
was directed at the wrong thing you know
I was lucky that I have this film making
but just you know growing up in Alton
and being around kids whose fathers
worked at the steel mill and i think
that there's just that fine line of how
you can be a seemingly good person and a
smart person and make a bad decision
because I made you know a lot of bad
decisions in my life and there's that
part of me that thinks jeez you know had
had just been a different scenario
different set of circumstances you know
maybe wouldn't have been as fortunate
and and also i think you know I've been
around a lot of people have been to jail
just through just my own personal my own
personal life you know I've never spent
time in jail but I have put myself i've
i've been in communities and and through
different things and I've been around a
lot of recidivism people in and out
so and i found interesting that you said
that a lot of times those very people
won't see some of these films that are
about that very subject or about certain
things in their lives that have brought
them there may be outside their
circumstances maybe because of what they
do whatever mm-hmm so can you talk about
that I mean you're making these films
that there's some very deep issues
running through them they're not you
know musicals or you know there's some
very you know dark subject matter that
obviously you'd like to show what is it
about that and and how do you like to
transcend with the story for me it just
I mean it's just kind of dealing with
the relationships I mean not not so much
about the the institution of a prison or
jail or the correctional side of it I
mean I don't feel like I've never served
lot any time so I don't I'm more
focusing on the rebuilding the process
of rebuilding and what was the question
again I'm just lost my train of thought
I guess I'm curious what what drives you
to look at those things but I think you
answered it because you said you know
you've known people and that you've
looked at your own life and you've said
well if it weren't for this or that you
know I could be in the same spot and I
think maybe a lot of people don't look
at that you know they just point a
finger and say oh those people are way
different from me you know their their
quote bad or whatever by our own fault
which some of it could be their own
addiction or whatever but in others it
could just be a set of circumstances so
I well yeah I mean I definitely think
had I not found filmmaking and been and
been struck by this passion of what I've
been struck with since a very young age
I could have been a very very aggressive
aimless person walking around with a lot
of
you know being too smart for my own good
and stuff like that not coming from a
good family you know i do see a side of
me and anger a passion of that I has
allowed me to be so tenacious to get
films made because I'm not like a
run-of-the-mill person like I'm pretty
intense you know whether it comes to
figuring out with my career or you know
I'm an extreme person and if you take
out if you take away my filmmaking and
you take away my art and what I love to
do and then you know that's gonna I'm
gonna have consequences within myself
and that's what I had that's a struggle
in my everyday life that I have to deal
with so i think that's honestly why i am
selected in prison and recidivism well
yeah because I mean it's almost that
same obsession whether it's hey gotta
find my next fix or whatever it is but
if you turn it toward wow there's a
story idea and you ruminate over it and
you obsess over it it's the same you're
taking yourself out of your present
situation and you're you're focusing on
something else I've been around a lot of
addiction and seriously and that's you
know that's part of my story and so it's
but I think a lot of people who are
creative and who are you know I'm not
speaking about myself but who possessed
the the zeal and the skill and the the
passion the really driving force to
build a career you know that's going to
manifest itself in a lot of different
ways whether it's through addiction or
whatever you know and in the book you
talk about female addiction and I find
interesting because it's sort of like a
Scarlet Letter you know curious why you
chose a character like that especially
one that she wants to have a baby right
but because of some prior addiction
issues there's some problems with her
being what is it artificially
inseminated or there's a problem through
her addiction she can't get approved for
there for the treatment I think and they
say you know more or less she's gotta
clean up her act and she tells her
husband Paul I'm gonna clean up my act
and there's a process she starts that
process but she runs into more
obstacles to you know she goes back and
they can't see her it's not happening
fast enough because people who are
addicts and who who are passionate and
this woman smart you know they wanted
now and they when they don't get results
immediately they get mad so they find it
all they find an alternative way to go
about and that's exactly what this woman
does she she's you know she goes to her
drug dealer who's a father figure who's
also from South America these people are
South American they're from South
America she goes I you know I need help
with this with with getting my fertility
drugs can you help me you know she's
eager and she gets it you know and this
when she gets her way it creates these
barriers and all this back it creates
residual problems for her in this couple
you know and there's a big moral arc
that they each go through the husband
and wife on their own terms you know
they start out together and then they
take their own journeys because but they
never but they're always they're always
so close to one another but they go on
their own arc their own journey until
they come back at the very end and
they've each learned sort of their own
moral type of lesson despite a lot of
loss and pain and you know it's a really
crazy movie I mean it's intense and I'm
you know it's gonna it's going to be
something unlike I've ever done before
not that I've done so much work but I
really think it's some going to I'm
gonna push the envelope I'm gonna take a
lot of risks when you write strong
female characters what's driving behind
that because I understand that's not the
first time mm-hmm you enjoy well for
this one it was my experience with the
whole ectopic pregnancy when I was 22 23
24 23 years old or something mm-hmm that
was based on that experience and then
women who have known have struggled with
addiction and fertility issues would you
like these strong female character that
doesn't do anything I don't know I
haven't known many passive Wallflower
women in my life okay so um okay well
I'll let you know in all honesty I like
I've been I have had experience you know
and then do this to how women can use
sex as a weapon whether it's withholding
withholding sex or having sex they
really use it as a weapon and they use
it as as a way to control men and and it
goes both ways but that was definitely a
little kernel that I've experienced also
too there's this phrase called attention
hooker mm-hmm where people also use it
to draw people in you know there's a
manipulative side men and women do it
where they love to kind of flirt and
maybe they have no intention of ever
pulling the trigger so but that that is
their way of I don't even know where I'm
going with this like a terminal Thank
You Inchon hooker it's from my friend
songs oh right about it yeah okay
you